yes I think race still matters I think I
think the press likes to highlight
conflict more than they'd like to talk
about the good things that are going on
in this country and so I think in the
presidential race the idea and the
significance of race has been over blown
it's been blown out of proportion
and I think because of that it's made it
more significant than it needs to be but
race still matters and no matter where I
go I'm always going to believe be a
black man and I'll be seen as that and
it'll carry with it whatever stereotypes
or whatever beliefs that people have
about it and I know that when I go into
a situation but I don't let it become a
hindrance it just is what it is and I
think it's always going to mean
something it's always going to matter
but what we should be able to do is have
the moral capacity as individuals and
human beings to respect each other and
to expect the best out of anyone and and
to not judge them by the color of their
skin or where they came from but to
truly judge them on their on the content
of their character and I think
fundamentally the world will be a better
place if we if we're able to do that
we're not there yet
but I think we have a chance of being
there in the future and I think we were
moving in that direction